all right that's question two let me put
this to one side we will return to it
uh yeah let's pop it all the way out of
the way and let's read question three
together
this falls under the nature of proof now
so consider statement p
if f of x has a vertical asymptote at x
equals a then f of a doesn't exist
which of the following must be true and
what we're considering is
p and it's converse this is p
and then i need to be able to state the
converse and work out of all of these
different combinations
it's either they're both true they're
both wrong um false
or one of them is true and the other one
is false so i just need to sort out
which is which okay
so it might be helpful to uh first think
about
statement p because it's right there in
front of us um if f of x has a vertical
asymptote at x equals a
does it then necessarily follow that f
of a
does not exist so that it can't exist
now
the answer is uh this statement
statement p
um it is true how do i know well the
first piece of the puzzle is that i have
to recognize
when you say f of x what that means is
uh this has to be a function because
this is function notation right so i'm
dealing with functions
not relations that's important um for a
particular reason you'll see why in a
second
and then i've got a vertical asymptote
at x equals a so
let's think of some examples for what
this could be if i draw myself up a
quick and dirty
uh this is not an argument diagram this
is just a cartesian plane right
if i were to say well what's what's a
function i know about that has a
vertical asymptote at x equals a
and perhaps the first thing that you
went to was maybe if i think about
something like 1 over x
your old familiar hyperbola
right this has a vertical asymptote at
x equals 0. there you go and sure enough
f of 0 doesn't exist if you try to
substitute 0 into 1 over x you get 1
over 0
which is undefined so you think okay
well this this is an example
that doesn't prove that it's always true
can i can i think of some kind of
function
that has a vertical asymptote but f of
you know it has a vertical asymptote at
x equals a but if i substitute in a
i still get a value okay and you can
think of
graphs curves on a cartesian plane that
would do this
but the only problem is you break one of
the conditions of the question and i
wonder if you can work out which one it
is
if for example i were to give you a
graph and it had a vertical asymptote
like this so let's call that
x equals a and can i conceive of a graph
that would look something like this i'm
going to draw something like this
which looks very similar and then i'm
going to draw something like
this okay
now this looks really weird right what
is going on here
this is going to be a mess of a graph
you might think how could i even come up
with a function that does this
and the answer is it's not as hard as
you think maybe i should say
function's the wrong word as you'll see
in a second can i think of an
equation that would give me this the
answer is you can if you think about a
graph like that
you've seen graphs like this you've seen
it within extension one not
frequently because here i'm crossing a
horizontal asymptote and that doesn't
happen
very often but you can come up with a
function that'll do this
because horizontal asymptotes can be
crossed horizontal asymptotes don't tell
you anything about the function
in kind of the normal domain it only
tells you about the extremities right
so at positive and negative infinity i'm
approaching the horizontal asymptote
but i can cross it in the middle no
problem right so this
could exist and so in order to turn this
into
this all i have to do is take whatever
equation i had before swap my y's and my
x's
and you would get this graph now the
reason why i can say but this is not
possible
this this is not something i need to
consider is because of what i said right
at the beginning
i said f x has to be a function because
this is function notation
this graph that i've drawn over here is
not a function
it's a relation so there's no y equals f
of x that could give you this
you could have an equation that has x's
and y's in it
but it wouldn't be an f of x anymore um
it would be
you know an x equals f of y situation
and so
you can exclude that it's not going to
be possible so
what that means is uh statement p is
always going to be true if you have a
vertical asymptote on a function
and there's no way that um x equals a in
this case x equals zero
there's no way it can exist it's going
to be excluded from the domain
okay so what that does is it it tells me
p is true so any of the options where p
is false i can exclude so
p is false in this one p is false in
this one so it's just going to be either
a or b
now to then understand the next part i
need to be able to state the converse
what what is the converse of a statement
um it has to do with saying
okay if i can say this statement in one
direction can i say it in the opposite
direction
so at the moment what i've got is if f x
has a vertical asymptote x equals a
then f of a does not exist so you can
see
here's the if this is the antecedent
clause
right here f of x has a vertical
asymptote at x equals a
and then i've got the then right and
then here's the um here's the next part
right so
this is the condition this is the result
a converse
reverses the order so i would say the
converse could be stated as
if f of a doesn't exist
does that then mean f of x will then
have a vertical asymptote at x
equals a is it true that f of a not
existing
definitely guarantees you have a
vertical asymptote
now hopefully in the way that i'm saying
it and pausing on it and lingering
you're seeing this can't possibly be
true um
f of a can not exist without there being
a vertical asymptote and there are many
many examples of this so all i need is a
counter
example so let me give you two i could
think of a graph
in fact you um you saw ones that looked
a bit like this before
i could think of a graph where f of a
doesn't exist
where it looks fairly pedestrian but it
just has a hole punched out of it
this is a graph where x equals 0 doesn't
exist
but there's no vertical asymptote
there's no asymptotic behavior going up
towards positive or negative infinity
you might say what kind of function is
that
well this could be f of x equals x
squared on
x you might say isn't that equal to just
x and the answer is
no because if i just said it was equal
to x i'd get this entire line
but because this the way it's stated has
an x in the denominator
i can't divide through by zero here even
if you get zero in the denominator you
can't get zero divided by zero that's
undefined
so therefore you've got f of zero not
existing
without a vertical asymptote so there
you go there's a single count example
it's all i need
you might say though that's that's weird
like do we have any other example
you know less exotic examples the answer
is we have tons if you think of any
function
there's some kind of restricted domain
um you know say the square root of x
that only exists for x is greater than
or equal to 0
or if i say you know log x that only
exists
for positive values of of x you can't
even get
x equals zero so in this case if i take
any
a over here any negative value try and
put in
you know f of negative one it's not
going to exist for
f of x equals log x but
that doesn't mean that there is a
vertical asymptote at
x equals negative one there's a vertical
asymptote here
but there's no vertical asymptotes over
here there's nothing over there right
so this is the way that i not that
you're working was required for this
because it was a multiple choice
question
but this is the way that i reasoned it
i've got i'll just come back here
f of x is a function not a relation and
that's part of the the definition of you
know
function notation and i said vertical
asymptote
at x equals a it does imply that f of a
is undefined so that's statement p
um but when i have a look at the
converse that's not true and here are
the
examples that i gave a discontinuity
like that little hole punched out
or when you just outside the domain as i
said log x is my example there
so that gives us the reason why uh
b is the correct answer over here
okay now i've already got it on screen
so i might as well just very quickly
talk about question
four the argan diagram shows the complex
number z
and w where z lies in the first quadrant
uh w lies in the second quadrant so
there's a
there's w which complex number could lie
in the third quadrant and this was done
pretty well
but just so you can see what's going on
w
take away z which is the correct answer
you can see i can position over here by
vector addition what is w take away z
it's
w plus negative z so if z
is heading off it from the origin up
into the first quadrant
then negative z is going to look like
this
that's negative z or that'll be the
equivalent displacement vector
so that's why you can see me doing it
over here so if you start at w
you go down you add negative z you're
adding one vector after another
lands you over here in the third
quadrant so that's why w take away z
is fine real quickly you can see on the
diagram by the way
where would the other options be let's
see conjugate of z
that's going to be down here that would
you know z bar would be something like
that
2i z the 2 extends the magnitude so it's
going to be further away and then that
i its effect is rotating anti-clockwise
by pi on two radians
so therefore i guess i'd be somewhere
like let's see here so that looks like a
right angle to me that's using the same
magnitude roughly and i need to be twice
as far away so i'm just going to go
over there so that would be something
like 2i z and then what's the last one
negative w
let's do this in other colors because
it's getting busy here's his w so i'm
just going to
reflect across the origin because that's
what a negative sign
does so i'm going to go all the way over
here that'd be negative w and you can
see
all those options are outside of the
third quadrant so that's why we end up
with
option c